president Trump attacks his former
personal attorney Michael Cohen battle
breaks out over border funding and
Obamacare takes a hit in the courts I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
okay so many exciting things happening
to number one we started on time
unbelievable number two this is the last
week in fact before we actually go on
vacation so get in all of your knowledge
now because otherwise you're just going
to be out of it
but before we get to any of the news of
the day and there's a lot of news today
first I want to mention to you the
number one point two trillion that's how
much we owe other countries and to our
own unfunded debt this year as of 2018
economists say that by the end of 2019
we'll be spending more on the interest
on our national debt than we spend on
Medicare by 2023 organ to be spending
more than we do on our national defense
well if all of this makes you feel a
little bit insecure then you need to
make a plan you need to diversify
because what's your plan in case god
forbid the SNP takes a topple of 50
percent like it said a few years back
this is why you need some gold this is
why you need some precious metals i
diversify my portfolio you should ever
see your portfolio - and the folks that
I trust to do that are the folks over at
Birch gold group Birch gold group is a
hedge against inflation it's a hedge
against uncertainty the company I trust
with precious metals Birch gold group
they have thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star views an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau it's the holidays you can get
gifts for everyone get yourself a gift
for free this is their comprehensive 16
page get revealing how gold and silver
can protect your savings it can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of risky
stocks and bonds into a precious metals
IRA if that is something that you choose
to get your no-cost no-obligation kit go
to birchgold.com slash Bend that is
birchgold.com /ban see if diversifying
into precious metals makes them sense
for you Birch gold calm /ban they're the
folks that I trust with precious metals
diversification alrighty so we begin
today with all of the continuing hubbub
surrounding Michael Cohen so as we
mentioned last week the president is in
a bit of a legal trouble he's got a bit
he's got a bit of legal trouble here his
legal trouble basically consists of
Michael Kohn I don't think the Russia
investigation as I've said for a while
is going to come up with anything major
on the president maybe I'm wrong we'll
find out but when it comes to Michael
Cohen Cohen has basically made an
accusation that president Trump violated
campaign finance law that he instructed
him to violate disclosure law and also
personal giving limits by giving a bunch
of money to American media Inc to lock
up stormy Daniels's story or
he or he was intended to do that for
Karen McDougal and then he actually did
it without American media Inc he just
paid off stormy Daniels and that was an
in-kind contribution that was illegal
and President Trump had instructed him
to go ahead and do all of that well
president Trump responded over the
weekend by calling Michael Cohen a dirty
rat so he tweeted out remember Michael
Cohen only became a rat in quotation
marks after the FBI did something which
was absolutely unthinkable and unheard
of until the witch hunt was illegally
started they broke into an attorney's
office all caps why didn't they break
into the DNC to get the server or a
crooked office well a couple of things
first of all I do love that crooked
Hillary has now just become crooked so
we all know what come hints which is he
demands met an expert of brand I mean
you got to give that to him right he
just says crooked were like oh yeah he's
hacked no Clinton um but the but when it
comes to this tweet a couple of problems
number one it is not illegal to get a
warrant to search a lawyer's office they
went through the DOJ they went through
procedures they didn't break into
Michael Cohen's office it wasn't like
they went in there with a pry bar like
this is Watergate and then just broke
into Michael Cohen's office also if he
thinks that's bad then why is he
recommending that they should have
broken into the jail and see if it's bad
to break into Michael Kors I was like
it's so bad they did that it's criminal
why didn't they do it to the DNC say
look okay some Galaxies brain stuff
right there and he says that they should
have broken into Hillary Clinton's
office first of all they did get a copy
of the server we've talked about this on
the show before I don't like when non
factual information is put out there one
of the pieces of non factual information
you have heard over and over and over
again from people on the right side of
the aisle is that the FBI did not get
copies of Hillary Clinton servers that
they should have just seized the servers
that's not how any of this works
they made a copy of the server that's
normal procedure and this part is quote
unquote breaking into Hillary Clinton's
office they did actually dig up a lot of
her old emails they did subpoena all of
these materials by the time they got
there she already drilled holes in her
stuff so I'm not sure what breaking into
her office would have done or anything
in any case the the big the big headline
of this suite is him calling Michael
Kohn a rat you dirty rat yeah note to
the President of the United States a
couple notes number one listen to your
attorney
stop it please stop it this is a lawyer
it is painful to watch his clients like
I'm gonna defend myself don't do it
don't do it you're not a good lawyer if
you're a good lawyer then you wouldn't
have needed Michael Cohen because
Michael Cohen is not even a good lawyer
hey this is it no just stop
I feel like Willy Wonka in in Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory hey stop wait
come back no I mean if you like what
what is he doing second when he says
that Michael code only become a rat
after the FBI did something normally if
you watch mob movies which I'm fond up
if you like mob movies then when someone
is called a rat it is not because they
are lying usually they are called a rat
because they're telling the truth when
you have Jimmy Cagney going on you dirty
rat usually what he's talking about is
somebody in his orbit who's now talking
to the police in order to secure a
better deal for himself but not lying
and in fact it isn't it is in fact a
crime for federal prosecutors to suborn
perjury themselves so if federal
prosecutors were to put out evidence
that turns out to be false if they're to
pressure people into making false
statements for use in court then they
would be criminally liable for that so
Trump here in this tweet is doing about
ten different things none of them good
including calling Michael Cohen a rat
which makes him look like he's a mobster
it's just it's just dumb at his basic
case is very simple he should have just
said Michael Cohen is my lawyer Michael
Cohen's job is to make sure that
everything we did was according to the
law end of story
now we're done instead he didn't do that
and one of the reasons he didn't do that
is because he doesn't know I think what
evidence the FBI and the DOJ now have
with regard to what Michael Collins said
to President Trump so President Trump I
continues to dominate over these
investigations he ripped into Jeff
sessions over the hoax Russia probe so
there's that he says it looks here as
the general Flint's defenses are
incidental to something larger which is
for the prosecution to figure out if it
can find a path to Donald Trump without
quite knowing what that crime might be
it stops looking like prosecution and
more looking like a persecution of the
president that's Daniel Henninger over
at The Wall Street Journal which is true
he says thank you people are starting to
see and understand what this witch-hunt
is all about Jeff Sessions should be
ashamed of himself for allowing this
total hoax to get started in the first
place note the quote/unquote hoax did
not get started under Jeff Sessions this
investigation began in
sixteen in the middle of the
investigation sessions just recused
himself because sessions had been
implicated in talking with people in
Russia right during the during the
transition and he was part of the
campaign it's up Rudy Giuliani is the
president's personal attorney and there
are three really terrible jobs right now
in America I mean worse than any septic
worker there are three really awful jobs
president's personal attorney
president's press secretary chief of
staff all jobs that no sane human being
really want oh Rudy Giuliani has jumped
right in the middle that so the former
mayor of New York former 2008
presidential candidate he was out there
defending President Trump and he's
basically skipping to the end okay what
he's basically skipping to is that
President Trump didn't do anything
criminal even if he did bad stuff even
if he talked to Michael Cohen is not
really a big deal and so we are skipping
all the way to where I am already which
is I'm assuming that President Trump
probably told Michael Cohen to spend
money on stormy Daniels I'm assuming
that probably happened because I think
he did I'm assuming that President Trump
talked with Michael Cohen and American
media Inc about picking up the stories
of these various women all of that can
be true and he still didn't necessarily
commit a crime and that's what Giuliani
is saying so Giuliani is skipping all of
the middle steps and frankly I don't
think that's terrible I think there are
a lot of folks in the administration who
don't understand and when you're
constantly moving the goal posts as to
guilt and innocence
it actually looks worse if you just say
yeah president does a lot of stuff not
illegal that's probably a better answer
then the president didn't do it well the
president might have done it but not
what you're saying he did well the
president might have done what you said
he did but it's not that bad well it
might not be that bad
it might be kind of bad but it's not
criminal why don't just go to you know
what president doesn't lot of stuff not
criminal right that's actually a better
line but instead we've gotten this
constantly receiving line of gold posts
into the infinite distance and I think
that that's actually pretty bad PR
Giuliani's cutting through all that to
his credit he's saying with regard to
the Russia stuff that collusion is not a
crime that which is true he's saying
that nothing the president did maybe it
looks bad to you but it's not actually
criminal true and then he adds it was
over by election time which is a weird
kind of qualifier I know that collusion
is not a crime okay it was over with by
the time of the election okay well
the it it depends what the it is right
if he was cool if he was colluding with
Russia to affect the outcome of the
election then that would be a crime
collusion itself is not a crime
conspiracy is a crime so it depends on
what activity we are talking about her
but he's not wrong he's not wrong and
that's why there's a poll today from CNN
that shows about half of Americans are
not interested in impeachment at this
point which is actually up a little bit
over what it was a couple of weeks ago
and then Giuliani makes what is a pretty
good legal point he says you know when
President Trump wanted to keep stormy
Daniels silent the entire case against
Michael Cohen and President Trump on
this score rests on the idea that
President Trump wanted to silence these
women before the election this is the
case that's been made by former FEC
commissioners who have said that
President Trump paying off women is not
a crime because people do this every day
in public life they pay off women all
the time
that doesn't make it criminal signing
hush agreements is a well accepted part
of the legal status of the legal
profession the only question is whether
this particular hush money was paid off
with an eye toward the election and this
raises a legal question what if it's
both what if the president paid off
these women partially because of the
election but partially because he wanted
to keep it secret from his wife because
he didn't want Melania finding out all
about it and then throwing lamps at him
or something
what if it's both and that's the case
Giuliani makes he says listen I can
produce witnesses who say that President
Trump was just silencing these women not
because of the election only but because
these women were ready to come forward
and that was going to harm his personal
life who's Giuliani saying that I can
produce an enormous number of witnesses
that say the president was very
concerned about how this was going to
affect his children his marriage not
just this one but similar all those
women came forward at that point in time
that that tape with Billy Bush and all
of that it's all part of the same thing
and I know what he was concerned about
and I can produce 20 witnesses to tell
you what he was two weeks before the
campaign a damn right and he was good he
was concerned about all of it okay and
and that's not actually implausible you
know Stephanopoulos is is kind of
looking at that askance like all this is
happening right before the end of the
campaign when do you think these women
were coming forward in other words maybe
part of the factor here is not the Trump
wanted to pay these women off before the
election maybe part of the factor here
is these women knew that their pay day
was coming before the election and so
Trump now has a limited amount of time
to silence these women before his family
finds out about that if that's something
the president Trump is deeply concern
about and by the way the evidence is
pretty good that Trump likes silencing
these women regardless of whether
there's an election going on remember he
worked with Ami to silence stormy
Daniels back in 2011 having nothing to
do with the election
so again as I've been saying for two
weeks here the president's defense rents
on a couple of points point number one
is the idea that this had nothing to at
the election point number two is that
even if it has something to do with the
election that's Michael Cohen's fault
that's his lawyers well I don't think
that case is particularly bad but the
evidence is going to have to emerge
there's one piece of evidence we're
going to talk about in a second that
sort of cuts against the President on
that first score first let's talk about
your impending doom so I know you don't
want to talk about the fact that you're
gonna die someday you don't like to
think about the fact that they're going
to put your body in the ground we're up
to now gruesome about it or anything I
mean it's the Christmas season folks but
if you are preparing for that
eventualities well at the very least be
responsible human being don't think
about it again by going to policy genius
and getting yourself some life insurance
actually having life insurance feels
pretty good because getting peace of
mind doesn't need to be complicated
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford from there you can apply online
the unbiased advisors a policy genius
will handle all the red tape leaving you
free to do the things you actually enjoy
and policy genius doesn't make life
insurance easy only whether you're
shopping for disability insurance to
protect your income homeowners insurance
auto insurance that can help you get
covered fast so if you've been
intimidated or frustrated by insurance
in the past give policy genius a try
just go to policy genius calm to get
your quotes and apply in minutes you can
do the whole thing on your phone right
this minute policy genius the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance go
check them out right now hey so there's
one piece of evidence that is cutting
against the contention of President
Truman that is this old tape of
President Trump talking with Michael
Kahn this was revealed back in July by
CNN in which President Trump is talking
with Michael Cohen about paying hush
money for David pecker stories the
reason that this cuts against the
president's case that he just wants to
silence these women for the sake of his
family is because why is he talking
about this now in other words what he's
afraid of on this tape is that David
pecker who is the CEO of American media
at the National Enquirer that he has
basically a safe full of scandalous
material on the president and Trump is
afraid that pecker is gonna die like now
because the election is coming up now
maybe there's an ancillary reason for
that but this cuts against the
president's case that he's not worried
at all about the timing that still
doesn't answer the legal question as to
could the president people read about
both could he be worried about the
timing and also could it be worried
about the impact on his family and if it
is both does it have to be exclusively
one or the other you know that that's
really not clear from the wall let's say
that he's concerned that Melania is
gonna find out get mad at him but he's
also concerned that the election is
coming up people do lots of things for a
variety of reasons right you may you may
do something for two reasons is it that
you have to do it exclusively because of
the election or could you also have done
it in order to protect your family in
case here's if you recall some of the
tape from presidents from talking to
Michael Cote about this reveal back in
July I need to open up a company for the
transfer of all of that info regarding
our friend David you know so that I'm
gonna do that right away I've actually
come up a call to me and I just spoken
to Alan why superb about how to set the
whole thing up with funding yes and it's
all the stuffing all the stuff because
here you never know where that company
never know where he's gonna get it
correct so I'm I'm all over that and I
spoke to Alan about it when it comes
time for the financing which will be
awesome
what what have I got okay so you know
again this is the president talking in
detail with corn about all this but
there is something about this tape that
people are missing and that is that
cohen keeps saying to trump I'll take
care of it I'll take care of it I'll
take care of it that's Trump's best
defense my Trump's best defense is
Michael Kahn said you take care of it
he's my lawyer the reason I keep
discussing all this stuff and this is
important the reason that this stuff is
important is because in the end the
calculus is going to be about whether
the president is impeached or not it's
really not about whether he did anything
criminal President Clinton did criminal
things the question is whether he this
is this is impeachable I think by the
standards of 1999 the answer has to be
no and that's why we're gonna run
through the 2020 election with this in
the back of the public's mind but I
don't think that he ends up being
removed from office for any reason nor
do I think that based on the standards
set by the American public
he should be based on what happened in
the Clinton impeachment which has
lowered the bar for all impeachments for
all the future okay so meanwhile we've
got how about breaking up breaking out
over
funding the Democrats say that they are
not interested in funding the border
wall in any way shape or form this
should be a win for the President of the
United States somehow the administration
seems to be ceasing defeat from the jaws
of victory on what should be a pretty
obvious PR campaign that the Democrats
are willing to allow us to be insecure
simply so that they can pander to a
particular base here's Chuck Schumer the
Senate Minority Leader saying that there
will be no wall in any form we're not
paying for any wall at all for no reason
no not happening
president Trump should understand there
are not the votes for the wall in the
house or the Senate he is not going to
get the wall in any form okay so when he
says that Trump's response should be
well if you won't give me the wall then
I'm not gonna sign a bill without the
funding for the wall instead Stephen
Miller who is one of the presidents top
advisors particularly an immigration he
went on TV and he decided to parrot what
the president wants him to say this is
why it personality matters in the
presidency the presidents of the United
States would be significantly better
served if he allowed PR professionals to
do their job as opposed to him watching
the shows and then deciding whether he
likes what people are saying and how it
makes him feel on the inside of his
heart Stephen Miller says a lot of stuff
President Trump wants to hear but it's
not good for the president's PR campaign
I'll explain why in a second here's
Miller explaining that Trump will in
fact shut down the government what is
the president's plan and will he shut it
down to get this five billion in border
wall funding we're gonna do whatever is
necessary to build the border wall to
stop this ongoing crisis of illegal
immigration and that means this is a
this is a very if it comes to it
absolutely this is a very fundamental
issue at stake is the question of
whether or not the United States remains
a sovereign country whether or not we
can establish and enforce rules for
entrance into our country the Democrat
Party is a simple choice they can either
choose to fight for America's working
class or to promote illegal immigration
you can't do both okay so he's totally
right about all of this when he says
Trump will absolutely shut the
government down over the border for
border wall fight when he says that he
shouldn't be owning it right that the
Trump wants to say that cuz Trump likes
feeling aggressive but the point here is
the Democrats are shutting down the
government by not giving the funding
that is necessary and this is a winning
battle for Republicans it is a winning
battle for Republicans again it's being
blown on the back of
bad PR but it is a winning battle I'll
give another example so last week there
was a case we talked about on Friday of
a seven year old girl who died while she
was in Border Patrol custody of
dehydration she was flown by helicopter
to a Medical Centre to take care of her
she didn't even know she was in
dehydration until shortly before she
started seizing up basically and now's
the fault of her father who brought her
over thousands of miles not giving her
any food or any water and then she dies
in American custody and this leads the
left to suggest that it is president
Trump's fault Stephen Miller has asked
about this and here is Stephen Miller's
response to the seven-year-old girl's
death now the answer is why the
seven-year-old girl died
well the seven-year-old girl died
because her father didn't take care of
her and he didn't take care of her
because he thought he could get any
legally listen to Miller's answer
because it's kind of a problem our
hearts break for the tragic death of the
seven-year-old girl
the loss of that precious life is
horrifying back here a hundred thousand
unaccompanied alien children or children
traveling with adults showed up at our
southern border mm-hmm president Trump
took dramatic action issued an executive
order directing illegal traffic to the
ports of entry but a left-wing activist
judge issued a reckless nationwide
injunction the president's order putting
thousands of lives at risk and further
enriching these grotesque a so again
this sort of charged language with
regards to left-wing courts are
responsible for all of us the reality is
that the person responsible for this is
the girl's dad right the person
responsible for all of this is the
father who didn't feed the child and
he's not again a lot of this is about
tone a lot of this is about presentation
but the problem with this then the
president tweets out about this sort of
stuff so the president tweeted about
child separations now his answer on
child separations should be the child
separations are bad the child
separations are being mandated by the
courts of the United States which is
true instead the president tweets out
the Democrats policy of child separation
on the border during the Obama
administration was far worse than the
way we handle it now remember the 2014
picture of children in cages the Obama
years so far so good but then he says
this however if you don't separate far
more people will come smugglers use the
kids it's that sentence however if you
don't separate far more people will come
now the implication is that he wants to
separate children from their parents
when they
get to the border which he doesn't want
to do hey so this is this is where a
little bit of forethought when it comes
to messaging would be very very useful
because I think that it's quite possible
for Republicans to win both this battle
and win the war when it comes to
immigration but they're gonna need to do
a little bit better job on the PR now in
just a second
gonna get to the other big story that
happened over the weekend and that was a
big ruling against Obamacare basically
striking down Obamacare in its entirety
from Texas now this didn't end with an
injunction against Obamacare but we'll
explain all the details coming up in
just one second so selling your home
it's one of the biggest decisions you're
going to make hiring the wrong real
estate agent can cost you thousands of
dollars I know I've done it before
and it's a real problem I've had to fire
real estate agents and get new real
estate agents because some agents are
just better at selling than others some
are great at buying but the way that you
can tell who is good and who is not is
you use home light home like techcom
it's the innovative solution that makes
it easy to find the best real estate
agent for you why do you need a top real
estate agent well because on average top
agents sell homes in eight days eight
days faster and nine percent above
asking price which could mean thousands
of dollars back in your pocket home
light is 100% free it's unbiased it
takes less than two minutes unlike some
other real estate sites agents actually
can't pay to advertise on home light
instead home light uses data from over
38 million home sales and two million
agents to recommend top real estate
agents for you home light brings trust
and transparency to the real estate
space so you can buy or sell with
conference no no that you are working
with the best agent for your needs
they've actually introduced over two
hundred forty seven thousand buyers and
sellers to top local real estate agents
and facilitated over six billion dollars
in real estate transactions so if you're
planning to sell your home this spring
now is the best time to find a great
real estate agent and to make it even
better home light has a special offer of
two listeners get started today you can
earn up to five hundred bucks when you
buy or sell your home using a home light
referred real estate agent go to home
light comm slash Shapiro today that's
home light comm slash up hero
hom e li ght light home light calm / up
here oh and go check that out for up to
five hundred bucks when you find the
best real estate agent and buy or sell
your home with home light terms and
conditions apply really that's that's a
pretty solid deal so go check that out
okay over the weekend big news a court
ruled that Obama care was not
constitutional so what made Obamacare
not constitutional this time considering
that it already been held constitutional
by the Riddick
this decision of Chief Justice Roberts
you'll recall that back when Obamacare
was passed there was a lawsuit went all
the way to the Supreme Court saying that
it was essentially a fine on the
American people for not buying something
which you can't do right there's nothing
in the Constitution that gives the
federal government power to do that and
Judge Robert Chief Justice Roberts
completely rewrote Obamacare to suggest
that it was merely a tax well there's a
problem with that now according to a
Texas judge the problem is that when
Republicans got rid of the penalty for
failing to pay the tax what they
actually did was they reverted the
entire quote-unquote tax back into being
merely a penalty itself and that's
unconstitutional and that makes the
entire law unconstitutional so here's
the way this works Chief Justice Roberts
is rewriting of the law essentially
suggested that the way that this works
is that you were forced to buy Obamacare
if you didn't you paid a penalty we said
right that's a penalty that's not a tax
Oh Robert said no it's a tax it's just
like any other tax and if you don't pay
a tax then you are penalized because you
violated the law right well what happens
when you get rid of the penalty if you
get rid of the penalty then it's no
longer a tax because there's no penalty
attached to it so that means that it's
just a rule that you must buy something
and that is in and of itself
unconstitutional that is what this Texas
judge found judge read Conners according
to The Wall Street Journal editorial
board ruled for some twenty state
plaintiffs that the Affordable Care
Act's individual mandate is no longer
legal because Republicans repealed its
financial penalty as part of the 2017
tax reform recall that Chief Justice
Roberts joined four justices to say
Obamacare semantics was illegal as a
command to individuals to buy insurance
under the Commerce Clause the framers
gave Congress the power to regulate
commerce not to compel it he wrote yet
the chief famously salvaged Obamacare by
unilaterally rewriting the mandate to be
attacked enter Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton who argues in Texas versus
United States that since Congress has
repealed the individual mandate the tax
is no longer tax and Obamacare is thus
illegal judge O'Connor agreed with that
logic he went further in ruling that
since Congress said the mandate is
crucial to the structure of Obamacare
all of Obamacare must fall along with
the mandate well first of all the
original decision was bad but that
doesn't mean that this particular
decision is legally good there are a
couple of problems with this particular
legal decision one legal complication as
The Wall Street Journal correctly points
out is that Congress
20-17 repealed the financial part of the
individual mandate but not the structure
of the mandate itself so the structure
of the mandate didn't change if it was a
tax it's still a tax just because you
reduced the amounts of penalty to zero
doesn't mean that legally speaking a
penalty doesn't apply Republicans used
budget rules to pass tax reform so they
couldn't actually repeal the mandates
Express language also the Affordable
Care Act has been up and running since
which means so-called reliance interest
come into play when considering a
precedent millions of people now rely on
Obama care subsidies and rules which
argues against judges repealing the law
by Fiat here's where I disagree with the
wall street journal' if it is
unconstitutional it's unconstitutional
but the Wall Street Journal correctly
says that the that judge O'Connor is
Right the Democrats claim the individual
mandate was essential to the affordable
care act but when Congress killed the
financial penalty in 2017 it didn't kill
Obama care it left Obamacare intact so
if you're deciding congressional intent
whether it's to kill Obamacare or not
well the severability provision of
Obamacare still applies in other in
other words the decision may be
psychologically satisfying but it's not
legally great what's more important is
that the decision itself actually cuts
against Republicans politically because
in the end this decision is not going to
stand in all likelihood the Fifth
Circuit Court of Appeals strikes it down
if not the Supreme Court probably
strikes it down and here's the problem
President Trump tweeted out very excited
that Obamacare had been struck down by
this court he tweeted up as I predicted
all along Obamacare has been struck down
as an unconstitutional disaster now
Congress must pass a strong law that
provides great health care and protects
pre-existing conditions Mitch and Nancy
get it done okay this is not great I'll
explain in a second and then he
continues along these lines
he says Wow but not surprisingly
Obamacare was just ruled
unconstitutional by a highly respected
judge in Texas great news for America
well here's why it's not great news for
America because there is no actual plan
to replace Obamacare
there's no bipartisan plan on the table
Democrats are immediately going to say
that if people lose their quote unquote
Obamacare coverage if they lose their
Medicaid coverage via Obamacare if they
are not for if all the rates go up
because a bunch of people withdraw from
the individual mandate on the basis of
Obamacare disappearing then they're
going to say oh look the health care
system has failed let's nationalize
health care this is this was always the
plan from day one this was the plan go
back and listen to things that I said
back in 20
twelve twenty thirteen twenty ten when
they were passing this this was always a
step by step design for failure program
so the Democrats could claim then when
prices went up it's because the market
was not regulated enough because where
Democrats come from the answer is always
more cowbell
if regulation fails the answer is always
more regulation always and so if
Obamacare fails even though they say it
was gonna cure the system or Obama in
2010 this is gonna make things more
affordable you like your doctor get the
keeper doctor you like your medicine you
have to keep your medicine I like their
insurance you gotta keep yours right
none of it was true none of it was true
but when it failed the plan was for him
to say well didn't see that one con yes
we gotta nationalize health care now and
that was always the plan for Democrats
it's why they are now pushing
single-payer health care it's why
they've embraced the full Bernie Sanders
strategy when it comes to health care
this is why Chuck Schumer is gleeful
about this decision Chuck Schumer is
happy about the decision why because now
he gets to try and force Republicans to
expand government to cover all the gaps
left by the crappy Obama care system
that was put in place back in 2010 here
is Schumer you can hear the Glee in his
voice we're gonna fight this tooth and
nail and the first thing we're going to
do when we get back there in the Senate
is urge put a vote on the floor urging
an intervention in the case the judge a
lot of this depends on congressional
intent and if a majority of the house
and a majority of the Senate say that
this case should be overturned it'll
have a tremendous effect on the appeal
okay so what he's saying is that
basically he's gonna get all of these
Democrats and Republicans to stand up
for Obamacare he wants people on the
record standing against this judge's
decision why because if you can get
people on the record standing in favor
of the judge's decision and then it
turns out that a bunch of people quote
unquote lose their health care or their
health care costs go up and he can blame
Republicans for this this is it's
fascinating when you look at Americans
opinions on health care basically
Americans are always in favor of the
status quo before Obamacare they hated
Obamacare now that Obamacare is in place
whenever there are major changes made to
Obamacare people say they don't want it
people just want to be left alone this
is the basic rule of American life
people mostly want to be left alone and
that means that once the status quo has
changed they don't actually want the
status quo changed more the problem is
that President Obama and the Democrats
put America on a path towards
single-payer health care
and Republicans by accepting the
premises of all of the Democratic
arguments that that we have to create a
government structured system where
people with pre-existing conditions are
covered for example by doing all of that
what they have actually done is placed
us on the same pathway because now
Republicans are arguing about how we get
there they're not arguing about what the
end goal is when it comes to the role of
government in health care the role of
government in health care should be
minimal it should not be high levels of
regulation it should not be that we are
going to quote unquote provide health
care to the ends of the earth for
everyone because no one can do that
there's so many lives told about the
health care system in America and abroad
it's pretty astonishing one of the great
lies told about America's health care
system is that it is unbelievably crappy
there are problems of America's health
care system for sure when you actually
remove car accident deaths and suicide
and gun homicide from America's national
death statistics and you look at our
life expectancy under the American
health system it is number one among all
industrialized countries people don't
like to point that out because it cuts
against the convenient argument that
America's health care system is
dramatically awful and people are dying
in the streets but that's not true and
when it comes to the idea that we are
spending inordinate sums of cash on our
health care system that is also not true
in the sense that if you look at as a
percentage of GDP per capita in the
United States what we spend we are
directly along the trendline of the rest
of the industrialized world that is not
to say we have the ideal system we don't
our system can be made better with more
deregulation more capacity to sell over
state lines less crammed downs from the
federal and state governments on
insurance companies more movement toward
early buying of catastrophic health care
insurance but instead of focusing on
actual solutions it turns into a fight
over pre-existing conditions and that's
a fight Democrats are destined to win
because the reality is that no one is
going to insure someone with a
pre-existing condition unless somebody
else is subsidizing that care in just a
second I want to get to the media
malfeasance over the weekend plus I got
to get to the story that is just insane
and speaks to what a lot of folks on the
radical green Left think about humanity
as a whole and get to that in just one
second first understand about how you
can defend your life when the founders
created the Constitution they protected
your rights but when they protected your
rights one of the things that they did
was make sure that you could protect
your rights with another right right the
right to keep and bear arms
I strongly
in that principle as you know and that
is why I really am excited to be
endorsing Bravo company manufacturing
they were started in garage by marine
bet more than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer
manufacturer of life-saving equipment
they assume they each rifle leaving
their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas each components of a
BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans so a life-saving standard
DCM feels a moral responsibility to know
that when they provide you a tool that
it is going to work when god forbid
something real is at stake to learn more
about bravo company manufacturing head
on over to bravo company MFG comm you
can discover more about their product
special offers and upcoming news as
Bravo Company MFG comm you need more
convincing find out even more about BCM
and the awesome people who make their
products they really are great I've met
them youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
that's youtube.com slash Bravo Company
USA check them out again at Bravo
Company MFG dot-com ok well I want to
get to the craziest editorial of the day
in just one second plus an insane story
about anti-semitism openly being
endorsed by the New York Times we'll get
to that in just one second but first
you're going to have to go over to daily
wire and subscribe because we have so
much good stuff coming up coming up in
2019 the Venge shapiro radio show will
be extending to three hours that is
right that's right the Ben Shapiro radio
show will be now adding a full two hours
with all of the great content that you
have come to enjoy and expect well
unless you listen to it live on radio
you're not gonna be able to hear it
unless you subscribe if you subscribe
then you get it right you get to get the
rest of it we are going to be taking
some questions during the breaks so
you'll be able to actually interact with
me during on a daily basis which is
awesome also it's almost time for the
next episode of the conversation which I
could not be less excited about I will
be wasting my time taking your questions
and answering them to the best of my
abilities live on air so make them good
make the questions going to make sure
that you show up I mean if I'm gonna be
miserable here sitting with a leech of
Kraus then you may as well be here I
mean I don't know what to expect of you
like I look I know that you've been
forced to listen to answers from idiots
like Michael Knowles and past but I will
be
providing real answers when I'm here I
expect you to be here once again
subscribers get to ask the questions
everybody gets to watch also that's
that's all the subscribership $9.99 a
month for $99 you get this as you know
hold routine greatest and beverage
vessels it's awesome you'll love it
keeps hot drinks hot and cold drinks
cold how do it no it's spectacular go
check all of that out and subscribe over
at youtube or itunes also the
iHeartRadio awards podcast awards are
coming up so go over to I Heart Radio
comm and then vote for us in the best
news category so that we don't have to
watch pod save America win stuff stuff
that's just that that would be
inappropriate go check that out right
now overnight you can write you can vote
like 5 times so it's as I say just like
an election in Cuba go check that out
right now and I Heart Radio comm and
again subscribe iTunes leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so well we talk whenever we talk about
politics one of the issues that comes up
is the the fact the media are wildly
biased against the right
the latest example comes courtesy of The
Washington Post
it's an opinion piece by max boot so max
boot is one of the actual nevertrump
errs meaning people who not only did not
vote for president Trump in 2016 but
also think that everything that
President Trump does is evil doesn't
matter the max boot agreed with half
this stuff before President Trump was
president now kids reversed his
positions on everything everything that
President Trump does is bad and terrible
and no-good and garbage right this is it
this is max boots perspective and it's
kind of sad and watch that honestly
because I've read a bunch of max boots
books particularly on foreign policy and
I find them really interesting I think
he's a good historian but he now has a
piece about the Weekly Standard now is
your recall late last week the Weekly
Standard which is a long time kind of
legacy conservative publication it's
been around for about a quarter century
and it was very anti-trump during 2016
it has remained pretty anti-trump since
then they went out of business the
Washington Examiner which owns them or
the parent company of the Washington
Examiner shut them down well President
Trump celebrated that which frankly was
untoward I mean it's it's what we've
come to expect from a president who just
does not know when to keep his mouth
shut he tweeted out the pathetic and
dishonest Weekly Standard run by failed
prognosticator Bill Kristol
who like many others never had a clue
his flat broken out of business too bad
may it rest in peace you may agree with
him about Bill Kristol you may agree
with him about the weekly standard but
celebrating a bunch of people getting
thrown out of their jobs two weeks
before Christmas it's probably not great
strategy in any case that's not what I'm
commenting on right now what I'm
commenting on right now is this piece by
max boots max boot says that in the
Washington Post conservatism needs a new
Weekly Standard untainted by Trump and
the entire piece is about how
conservatism requires a new magazine
that is not going to do love Trump it's
just going to deal with ideas and
conservatives can talk about ideas
without having to deal with Trump and
yada yada yada now I agree with a lot of
that sentiment I agree that the battle
over conservative ideas is much more
important and much more long-lasting
than the battle over whatever President
Trump is doing today I think it's
important why we talk about ideas on the
show on a regular basis why we do the
Sunday special it's why I write
books on Plato and Aristotle and
judeo-christian values is why I talk
about the social fabric I agree with all
of this
the problem is writing this in the pages
of the Washington Post is a is a why and
the reason I say that it is a lie is
because the Washington Post cannot print
pieces or should not print pieces
talking about the lack of good
conservative content when it will not
hire a conservative will not hire a
conservative now there people say well
you a daily where you're not hiring
people who are on the left number one
I'm sure that we have employees here who
don't agree with my politics but second
of all we are open about our political
biases this is a right-wing site right
Daily wire is a right-wing site I am a
conservative I'm very open about this I
have never hidden it and I think it's
unethical to hide your own political
proclivities when you're writing news
because people can then take what you're
saying what the particular grain of salt
necessary The Washington Post when it
prints pieces in which it says things
like conservatives ought to do X or
conservatives ought to do Y the
Washington Post is a supposedly
nonpartisan paper there is not one major
conservative working for the Washington
Post
not aa major conservative working for
The Washington Post at least the New
York Times can say that it's got people
like Bret Stevens or people like Ross
dude hat like these are folks who
actually are conservative thinkers even
if they are anti-trump the Washington
Post can't name a conservative thinker
how do I know this because I personally
know a person who was interviewed by The
Washington Post is not me and I'm only
not mentioning his name because I think
that he would be upset if I did and he's
asked me not to he was interviewed by
the heads of the Washington Post to join
their editorial page to be one of the
columnist on the editorial page he went
through the entire process he went
through a bunch of meetings and he was
in it was indicated to him that he was
going to be hired on the editorial page
as a regular columnist who sort of
filled the Charles Krauthammer role
after Charles Krauthammer is passing and
they went through all the interview
processes he got to the final interview
they were basically ready to offer them
him the job then he was called in they
cancelled the they canceled the meeting
apparently where he was going to be
offered and he was brought into the
offices of the higher-ups at the
Washington Post where he was told in no
uncertain terms that staffers at the
Washington Post were very upset at him
why were they upset at him they were
upset at him because of his opinions on
transgenderism
because he believes that male and female
are biological categories and so because
in they asked him better he said no I'm
not gonna change my opinion nor my going
to apologize for these statements I've
made on this particular score and I
don't think it makes me an unsympathetic
person to say that male and female are
biological categories this was too much
for the Washington Post which quickly
ended any flirtation had had with him
job wise when the mainstream media
laments the death of true conservatism
but they will not hire anyone who really
they won't and they listen Ross dude hat
could not get hired today by the New
York Times
Barry Weiss would not be hired today by
the New York Times she's not even
conservative Barry I mean I know Barry
Barry is if she's conservative she's at
the far left of conservatism right and
Barry would say that she's more of a
centrist they would not hire these
people and then they complain that
there's not a real conservatism right
because you get a wise the conservative
movement and then you're surprised when
it acts like a ghetto all of that is is
just plain garbage but you know who does
get space and the editorial pages of
these various publications are the most
radical leftists this is something that
is shocking to me I've said before I
think the conservative movement is
significantly better at policing itself
than the people on the left and I've
been a long drawn-out arguments with
folks with my friends on the left you
say no no no the right is constantly
having to throw people out and my answer
is right but the kind of the right does
constantly throw people out when is the
last time you saw someone on the left
say something so radical that the left
said you know what can't be associated
with that person when is the last time
that happened has it ever happened I
cannot name a example like one can you
name one example of a person who said
something so radically so radical
politically not just you know said
something gross or something but
somebody who said something so radical
politically at the left went you know
what don't want to touch that person
with a ten-foot pole and yeah what we're
done here where we can't have this
person associated with us I've never
heard that happen to anyone
hey and that's why the right looks at
the left may say you guys have no
standards you got you're gonna police us
you're gonna tell us how to police and
then you're gonna tell us what we should
tolerate and what we shouldn't tolerate
you guys want police yourselves how do
we know this because if you're on the
Left you can get away with just about
any freaking thing this is an amazing
story from tablet today about the the
author of the color of purple Alice
Walker
so she was asked in its New Times Book
Review which published a full
length interview with her she was asked
a question what books are on your
nightstand she replied with for the
second book was and the truth shall set
you free by David a key in inky's book
she says there is the whole of existence
on this planet and several others to
think about a curious persons dream come
true now as the tablet writes about yet
a Rosenberg caught it he says this pass
without comment from the New York Times
interviewer and the publication passed
it on to readers without qualification
this is rather remarkable because the
book is an unhinged anti-semitic
conspiracy tract written by one of
Britain's most notorious anti-semites in
the book the word Jewish appears 241
times the name Rothschild has mentioned
three hundred and seventy four times
these references are not compliments
indeed the book was so obviously
anti-semitic that it keys publisher
refused to publish it and he had to
print it himself in the book and
elsewhere icky drawers liberally upon
the infamous anti-semitic pamphlet the
protocols of the Elders of Zion a
Russian forgery about an alleged Jewish
global cabal that is widely considered
one of the most influential anti-semitic
works in history magnanimously icky
calls the hate track by a different name
as he writes in the book promoted by
Alice Walker in the very late 1800s if a
controversial document came to light
called the protocols of the Elders of
Zion I called them the Illuminati
protocols and I quote many extracts from
them in the robots rebellion some say
there were a forgery made public only to
discredit Jews and I use the term
Illuminati protocols to get away from
the Jewish emphasis if they were a
forgery something that is quite possible
what were they afford Rio and by whom
the authors of the best-selling book
Holy Blood Holy Grail conclude that the
original protocols were indeed authentic
so it's I mean Alice Walker's allowed to
get away with this and she is loud 'add
as a great thinker of our times at just
the same way that James Baldwin who was
loud it as a great thinker back in the
1960's and 1970's routinely engaged in
Nancy's medical writing he actually did
go back and read his writing they're a
bunch of banshees medic references and
throughout it and he wrote an entire
essay about why the Jews were part of
the the white supremacist movement in
the United States etcetera etcetera
bottom line is again just like the
women's March if you are on the left and
you are anti-semitic can get away with
it and if you are radical just
politically radical there is nothing too
politically radical for the left the
same people who say oh how dare the the
right police the Weekly Standard listen
I disagree with how the Weekly Standard
was
but I'm not gonna sit here and listen to
how the right should police itself from
the left which refuses to police itself
and refuses to hire mainstream
conservatives and ghettoize as those
conservatives while simultaneously
accepting the worst of the worse there's
an article today by a guy named Todd May
a professor of philosophy at Clemson
University and apparently a professional
useless person the title of his piece in
The New York Times would human
extinction be a tragedy
this is fit for print he says there are
stirrings of discussions these days in
philosophical circles about the prospect
of human extinction this should not be
surprising given the increasingly
threatening predations and climate
change and reflecting on this question I
want to suggest an answer to a single
question one that hardly covers the
whole philosophical territory but is an
important aspect of it would human
extinction be a tragedy and it has well
it'd be a tragedy but it would be a bad
thing because we're mean to animals
right if this were if he says the
elimination of the human species if all
that it were were just people being mean
to animals then it would be a good thing
full stop but we bring things to the
planet other animals can't we bring an
advanced level of Reason we engage in
arts and scientists where our species to
go extinct all of that might be lost he
says in many dramatic tragedies the
suffering of the protagonist is brought
about through his or her own actions and
Oedipus's killing of the father that
starts the Train of events that leads to
his tragic realization its leaders
high-handedness toward Cordelia that
leads to his demise it may also turn out
that it is through our own actions that
we human beings bring about our
extinction or at least something near
contributing through our own practices
for our own tragic end so he says that
maybe the extinction of humanity would
make the world better off and yet would
be a tragedy writing in the new york
times better if humans didn't exist
strong case to be made that if you think
that you know you have a solution but
it's nothing too radical for the left
nothing too radical for the left but but
but then they will lament the death of
true conservatism pretty pretty
astonishing stuff okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like this week
is Ludwig van Beethoven's birthday ya
gotta love me some Beethoven the
Beethoven Violin Concerto is a truly
great work of art one of the great
violinist of our time Hilary Hahn who is
fantastic I once saw her perform live I
in in where was it it was a
Wisconsin it was Door County Wisconsin
and she is just terrific
here she is playing the Beethoven Violin
Concerto which was not truly appreciated
at the time it was only later that it
became sort of part of the great cannon
um they're a bunch of great cadenzas to
this concerto I loved playing this
concerto one of the great cadenzas to
this concerto is by Fritz Kreisler
that's alone that I usually play but
here is Hilary Hahn playing with I'm
trembling which Symphony that says she's
playing me Beethoven Violin Concerto
we're gonna do Beethoven all week thanks
to his birthday
[Music]
it's it's just great music gogo listen
with Beethoven Violin Concerto beautiful
music the the second movement is
incredible the third movement is fun
it's it's just becomes fantastic so
thank you to Ludwig van Beethoven for
giving us some of the reason why human
being should continue to exist on the
planet yay idiots
hey just okay meanwhile other things
that I like good for Sam Harris so Sam
Harris who is I'm friends with Sam and
Sam is a principled guy we disagree on
religion we disagree on some aspects of
our politics for sure but Sam has now
closed his patreon account why because
patreon has not been clear and its
standards from what allows you to keep
patreon open he tweeted out today and
this is a personal financial sacrifice
for Sam who has a lot of people who give
him money on patreon says dear patreon
supporters as many of you know the
crowdfunding site patreon has been
several prominent content creators from
its platform while the company and says
each was in violation of its Terms of
Service
these recent expulsion seemed more
readily explained by political bias
although I don't share the politics of
the band members
I consider it no longer tenable so
expose any part of my podcast funding to
the whims of patreon trust and Safety
Committee I'll be deleting my patreon
account tomorrow if you want to continue
sponsoring my work I encourage you to
open a subscription at Sam Harris org
slash subscribe as always our main
deeply grateful for your support wishing
you all very Happy New Year Sam good for
Sam Harris and I think this is
increasingly the model you're gonna be
seeing used you know we hear a daily
wire have subscriptions specifically for
this purpose it's why we don't have a
patreon account because we are as Adam
coral likes to say a pirate ship and if
you want to join the pirate trip then
you should join us over here good for
Sam I think you're gonna see other
content creators
I would assume other members the
intellectual dark web it's why I'm proud
to be a member of the intellectual dark
web do this sort of stuff because there
has to be some stand against the
arbitrary and capricious nature of
social media good good for Sam Harris
really well done okay time for a couple
of things that I hate
so this is a pretty amazing piece by a
person named Luciano Guerra who is a
nature photographer and outreach
coordinator and educator for the
national butterfly center in Mission
Texas here is his piece in The
Washington Post I voted for Trump
now his wall may destroy my butterfly
paradise I kid you not that's the title
of an actual piece he talked about how
he works at the national butterfly
center which is a long us-mexico border
documenting wildlife and leading
educational tours as many of our
visitors are young students from the Rio
Grande Valley when they first arrived
some of the children are scared of
everything from snakes to pill bugs here
we can show them animals that roam free
and teach them not to be afraid and
talked about how great the butterfly
paradise is okay into it then he says
president Trump's new border wall which
he has threatened to shut down the
government fund will teach them what it
takes to destroy a home for all kinds of
animals he says it'll cut through the
100 acre refuge sealing off seventy
acres bordering the banks of the Rio
Grande he says on the south side of the
barrier flooding will worsen on the
north side animals including threatened
species like the Texas tortoise and the
Texas horned lizard will be cut off from
ranging beyond the wall for feeding and
breeding he says all of this will be
super terrible he says he voted for
President Trump in 2016 I want our
immigration laws to be enforced and I
don't want open borders but mission is
not a dangerous place I've lived her all
my life
here at the national butterfly center
six thousand schoolchildren visit every
year when the president says there's a
crisis at the border that requires an
action as drastic as building a massive
concrete wall either knows it's not true
or he's living an alternative reality he
says that he didn't take Trump seriously
about the wall but now that he now that
he sees that it's going to affect the
butterfly paradise now he's not going to
back President Trump now one thing that
is obviously not seen in this piece from
the Washington Post right by the way
again the Washington Post's happy to
print anybody who is quote-unquote
conservative as long as they're saying
things that please the Washington Post
one thing it does not say is how many
people cross this poor area of the
border illegally there's there's no
actual there there's no actual
statistics on how many people crossed
the border in this area or how many
people would cross the border in this
area if it were left unprotected while
building a wall along other areas of the
border so it's just more media by but
again I think the title of the article
itself sort of discredits the article
okay other things that I hate today
so I have been saying for years that I
really really just like political
pandering
political pander
to me is mostly summed up in our modern
day and age my politicians going to a
purportedly victimized group and sayings
that purportedly victimized group you
are indeed victimized and now I am here
to protect you you see it from President
Trump when it comes to people who are
living in dying towns he goes there he
said well it's China and it's Mexico and
I'm gonna save your job and your towns
gonna bloom again and he's Tucker
Carlson when we had a Sunday
conversation says some of this sort of
stuff as well because he's more of a
protectionist on economic policy and on
the left you see this in racial term so
senator Elizabeth Warren who is just
dying in the polls I mean she's falling
apart there's a poll in Iowa over the
weekend it shows her at three percent in
Iowa at 84 percent name recognition and
three percent in Iowa put a fork in her
she's done she in the New York Times
they report senator Elizabeth Warren in
a commencement speech Friday at
historically black Morgan State
University mixed her trademark language
denouncing economic equality inequality
with more explicit indictments of racial
discrimination giving what could be a
preview of a possible appeal to black
voters should she run for president she
says the system is rigged
she says under the rules of commencement
speakers I'm required to say work hard
and you should but I'm here with a
bolder message it's time to change the
rules let me say that again for those in
the back change the rules I'm not a
person of color and I haven't lived your
life or experienced anything like the
subtle prejudice or more overt harm that
you may have experienced just because of
the color of your skin rules matter and
our government has systematically
discriminate against black people in
this country hey so this is this is her
way of working toward an intersectional
audience by basically saying to them
that you are all victims all these kids
are graduating it's amazing she's
selling a bunch of people who are
graduating from college with degrees
from an excellent university that they
are victims in the free society and
world history
she's a Morgan State on Friday miss
Warren revived her pitch surrounding
housing telling a story about her mother
struggles to keep her home and
contrasting that with the barriers
Americans face today should the rules
are rigged because the rich and powerful
have bought and paid for too many
politicians and she says there are two
sets of rules one for the wealthy and
the well-connected and one for everybody
else two sets of rules one for white
families and one for everybody else
that's how a rigged system works does
she really think that there's a set of
rules for white families and one for
everybody else does she really believe
that because if so I'd like for her to
point in to me to those rules that
maintain that system so we can talk
about them otherwise this is just her
going to particular
and saying you guys are victims vote for
me I don't like it when it's done by
anyone on any side of the political
aisle it is identity politics and
identity politics that is unsupportable
by the evidence is just gross pandering
so provide the evidence lady or or sit
down because this is it because this is
and that holds true for everyone it
holds true for President Trump doing the
the reason you're being victimized is
because you are living in the boondocks
and because you're being victimized by
foreigners and it holds true for
Elizabeth Warren going into black
communities where people are graduating
from college and telling them that your
hard work won't make a dime's but a
difference because America's racist
country just yuck
just yet you want to make the country
worse this is a pretty solid way of
doing it all so that you can gain power
which presumably she will then use to
destroy the free system that has created
the prosperity with which we live okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
pero show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing